so now we turn on this wednesday edition
of pro football talk live from
competitions that can be objectively
resolved to the inherently subjective
configuration of 32 teams as determined
by me
uh without
necessarily a whole lot of advanced
thoughts sometimes yes sometimes no it's
the power rankings not nearly as much
shake up this week as last week there's
the entirety of the list one through 32.
the steelers continue to be at number
one
chris yeah because
even though they weren't impressive
against the cowboys
but what was i gonna do move the saints
all the way up to number one with two
losses the chiefs weren't impressive
against the panthers that was their
opportunity if the chiefs had won by 21
points and the steelers had struggled
against the cowboys maybe i would have
moved the chiefs ahead of the steelers
but they both struggled but not enough
for the saints to overtake them although
although hey if the saints keep winning
38-3 they may get to number one despite
having two losses yeah and i i
understand you know what you're saying
with the one and two i'd probably still
put the chiefs at number one
just because of the
how bad the steelers looked and not that
the chiefs look great
but the chiefs at least had moments in
that game where they were close to where
you go oh they're gonna put it away oh
they're gonna put it away and then they
do something dumb or something like that
so i still disagree with you there at
one and two
but i understand your logic the raven
saints one at three and four how much
did you do splitting hairs there because
i will say
i think i'd probably still put the
ravens a smidgen ahead of the saints
but
i get it it wasn't the greatest win for
them with the colts they come off the
loss the saints have the big win but how
much thinking did you do there
um
not a whole lot no much as maybe you
think i i just what the saints did on
sunday night was so impressive and you
know we were still reeling from the fact
that we believed in the buccaneers to
win that game and we were so
badly wronged by what the saints did to
them that i you know i felt like that
was still resonating with me on monday
night when i was putting it together and
yeah i think they deserve to be number
three i mean i did think you know right
now
and it changes week in and week out but
based on what we saw from the saints the
other night
i i
i don't know would they beat the chiefs
if they played right now i don't know i
think they'd give them a hell of a run
for their money i do too i don't think
there's any doubt about that you know
again they do play they do play no they
do remember we drew told us that when we
were at the super bowl with them last
year when we asked them about the super
bowl winner that will be the 49ers and
chiefs he goes well we got to play both
next year and he we he weaseled out of
giving us an answer because of it uh but
i i'm with you and hey we've said all
along
that the saints have the potential to be
the most complete team in the nfc
we never really saw it till this week
that's where i don't understand some of
the backlash with that you know the
saints and how come you didn't pick them
and all that they haven't looked that
great this was by far their best game of
the year
in every aspect it really was and now
let's see if they can build on it i mean
if we see the next few weeks
where we go oh
you know okay they're winning let's not
say it's 38-3 but they're winning and
they're still looking a lot like they
did on sunday night football then hey
yeah maybe you got a case there to put
them at number one number two but um i'm
i'm
i want to just see it one more week of
just clean football i guess before you
start to throw them in the chief
steelers category
how about this fact as it relates to the
kansas city chiefs i saw this on twitter
yesterday and i can't remember where the
chiefs have now lost in the last
calendar year
one game
the game against the raiders that's the
only game they've lost since november 10
of 2019. they lost to the titans that
day that wild crazy regular season game
yeah where uh the titans what was it was
it a blocked field
field goal
yeah crazy thing at the end of the game
35 32 the titans won november 10 that's
the last time other than the loss to the
raiders this year that's the last time
the chiefs lost a game that's an
incredible incredible run
and you know one of the things i talked
to travis kelsey about on sunday they're
pissed off that they lost to the raiders
they have the bye week to get ready for
the raiders and they don't plan on
losing another game anytime soon and
somehow they're flying
under radar here's another fact about
the chiefs chris they've held a lead at
some point in the game for 51 straight
games including 45 games with patrick
mahomes who was 36-9 as a starter but
for 51 straight games at some point in
the game they've been ahead that is
unreal that is unreal and it speaks to
you know i to me you know again their
toughness they're they're more physical
than we give them credit for of course
my homes on that offense always answer
when they are down i mean we've really
never seen them not answer to where you
go oh we're going to have a game i mean
really the raiders game this year was
about as far as it's ever gotten out of
reach as far as i can remember with my
homes as a starting quarterback in
kansas city but then the other thing i
think it proves too is just their
defense is versatile and yeah it's not
statistically at the top of the league
all the time but they can match up
against any offense in football and i
think that's their greatness and we see
when they they're kind of like the same
they're you know they embody their team
when they're focused and on things they
stop things oh we're playing the ravens
we need to stop lamar jackson running no
problem they do it oh derek henry in the
afc championship game no problem we do
it you know they let up plays here and
there they lose their attention to
detail it seems like but yeah it speaks
to the bigger complete team that vich
and andy rita built there to where yeah
there's never a team that totally is a
mismatch for them in any way
points bet which is the official sports
betting partner of nbc sports has a look
ahead line where the afc representative
in the super bowl would be a two and a
half point favorite over the nfc
representative does that seem right to
you
i think it does i think it does too i
think the afc is clearly the more
quality conference there's no doubt you
know the nfc
you know we just talked with the saints
the bucks are the two teams we had in
there for most complete teams we know
there's issues with the packers they got
a great quarterback definitely i mean
they're in the mix seattle we know
there's issues there too
you know there's there's flaws with
every nfc team for the most part except
for really the the saints right now what
let's have some fun here yeah let's do
it chiefs let's say it's chief seahawks
what would the line be what would what
would you think the betting line would
be chief seahawks i'm gonna say chiefs
by four
i was thinking four and a half yeah what
if it what if it would be
uh chiefs saints
oh i think that'll be less yeah and they
will be and they will be they will be
playing later this year but i'm talking
about super bowl championships saints
what do you think i think it's gonna be
like
chiefs by two or one and a half almost
how about steelers bucks that was the
super bowl wow
wow
well i'm flawed right now with my mind
in the tampa bay area so it's like hard
to come up with a realistic one because
i still got that image of last week to
where i go well
right now i i guess i mean steelers are
going to be the favorites and i would
think that would be something like a two
and a half point spread something like
that as well somewhere in there
yeah it would be that was a tough one
one more before we move on yeah
chiefs
packers oh baby i don't know that would
be torture for me though i don't know
who i'd root for i don't know but i
think the chiefs of pro i'm gonna say
like three and a half in that one i'd go
with the chiefs yeah you know oh hey hey
you want real torture you want real
torture
packers bills oh that's real torture
it would be it would be and i would
think the packers would be favored in
that one by
i you know i don't that would be i think
a little closer than people might
realize maybe three three and a half
somewhere right in there i think that
would be dangerous though that'd be the
kind of matchup that josh allen them
could win if they got the super bowl
and i also think what happens by the
time you would rise up out of the afc
playoff field you would have a different
vibe around you than right now no that's
exactly it right i mean we see teams
that you know really come to a
culmination a lot of times in the
playoffs to where they hit their peak
play divisional championship game
weekend and they're a different team
than we even thought they were in week
13 or 14. so yeah this is still a work
in progress but i mean to the original
question i think you're you're right no
there's no doubt as far as the afc is
the better conference right now you're
seeing that hey i mean look at the afc
east
i mean what
the bills are what two and one against
the nf the great nfc west the dolphins
are what three in one one against the
great nfc west so that just shows you a
little right there and of course we've
seen the patriots beat the raiders and
be toe to toe with the chiefs so that
just speaks to you know we don't view
the afc east as this power conference
but yet we talk about the nfc west being
the best division of football and the
afc east is giving them a run for their
money
yeah no i agree with you completely and
uh who knows who's gonna come out of
that afc field but i feel like whoever
it is they are going to have an edge
over the nfc representative because i
just don't see that team that jumps off
the page consistently yeah it's just one
week it's his team one week it's that
team one week it's his team one week
it's that team and there isn't that that
you know that overpowering 49ers type
team that's just steamrolling right the
conference right we ask for questions
when we do this both on the pft twitter
page and on the chris sims twitter page
and there are plenty of questions here's
one as it relates to the ravens who are
now number four up three spots from last
week at toasty sam13 do the ravens have
the offense chris to win in the playoffs
that that will be the big question about
the ravens and i i don't know if you
listen to that little clip i had in the
show from my podcast a little bit
because i discussed this on monday you
know we're all critical lamar jackson
sometimes and oh can they win with the
drop back pass game and that's where i
had to check myself before i wrecked
myself last week as i was thinking about
it because i also gotta go wait let's be
realistic here yeah there's been some
moments where lamar could be
better in the past game but it's still
really damn good i mean it's really
we're being nitpicky with this guy a
little bit and i think the other thing
that just comes to me as i watch the
ravens on film so much is
you know
yeah i don't have faith in their past
offense and it has nothing to do with
lamar jackson i don't see
enough creative ways to get playmakers
the ball enough wide open players
you know just just not enough there in
the past game schematics that stress a
defense out and i think that to me is
something they really need to dive into
here down the stretch because i think if
they are going to beat the kansas city
chiefs you know and maybe have to beat
the steelers and who else in the afc
that at some point that's going to have
to rely on that pass game it's going to
and it can't just be lamar scrambling
and making plays or little short passes
over the middle is going to have to be
something more to that and i think
that's still a big question about their
football team
and as we get closer and closer to the
postseason that narrative is going to
get stronger and stronger because lamar
jackson and the ravens are oh and two
for as great as they are in the regular
season they're 0-2 in the postseason
john harbaugh told me after the win over
the colts as he explained that he's
leery about the patriots because they're
still the patriots they still have bill
belichick he pointed out we have a very
young team people don't realize how
young this team is they're still kind of
learning their way yeah and they have to
learn how to play in these big games
against tough opponents and i think part
of that is preparing them for having
some success in the postseason because
if they lose again this year the
narrative gets even stronger and it will
continue to grow and grow year in and
year out until they finally show they
can win in the playoffs we have the
bills at number six
um and at derrick rudolph has a question
as it relates to buffalo considering the
victory over the seahawks 10 points 44
34 are they back in the super bowl
conversation you know we had a gap yeah
between ravens chiefs titan steelers
and the bills
are they
are they closing that gap are they is it
a five-team conversation now in the afc
i don't know if i'm ready to go there
you know i don't know i i i don't think
i'm gonna say that yet i do think it
made me feel better about them
definitely and not even necessarily that
they just won by 10 points
but watching the film back too
to me their defense showed some
different aspects mike that was we
hadn't seen
i i don't know what it is but they kind
of played a different way this past week
against seattle i feel like it's like
sean mcdermott got back involved and was
like no wait wait we gotta do some more
of this and that and this it was a
little more creative they definitely
were more physical up front to where i
think they're teetering on that line of
the conversation but i don't think i
could put them in the class still
like i think i might have pulled
tennessee out of that group too right
now where i just go i'm not so sure
they're right on the fringe but like the
afc pittsburgh kansas city and baltimore
are for sure super bowl contenders and
then i feel like tennessee and buffalo
are the next group there that you go oh
they're close i'd like to see a little
more about this and that
um but but they have some qualities of
being a super bowl team i don't know
mike you feel the same way or do you
think buffalo is back in that super bowl
combo i i think they're moving toward
and i agree with you maybe the
combination the bills rising and the
titans sliding a little bit even though
the titans man handled the bills that
was now several weeks ago teams change
yeah they get better they get worse they
rarely stay the same we're gonna learn a
lot about the titans on thursday night
when they play the indianapolis colts in
the first of two matchups between those
teams which will likely decide the
champion of the afc south
uh
the seahawks
i moved them from number three down to
number seven after
losing in in as ugly fashion as they did
to the buffalo bills
um
i
i don't know how to feel about them i
know any given week you know the
cardinals kind of pop that bubble of
we'll always find a way to win and i
felt like against the bills we were
creeping toward that here they come here
come the seahawks doing seahawks things
and pulling a victory out of the jaws of
defeat you know the four interceptions
in the first half of the nfc
championship game from five years ago
it's just the setup for the dramatic
finish i kept thinking that's gonna
happen and maybe we're just at a point
where
there isn't enough around russell wilson
to let that occur chris no i you know it
it's it's a little scary i mean they
gotta have they need an adjustment on
the defensive side of the ball there's
just no other way to say it it's just
it's it's too easy for offenses at times
you know and i don't know what that
approach is going to be you know their
pass rush is a little bit better jamal
adams was out there but to me the big
thing is to where they need to rebound
it's just too aggressive i mean last
week it's just too much blitzing too
many dbs that are not that great and
man-to-man on a island versus receivers
that are much better than them you know
you know
third and 15 like the you know the play
we've talked about a lot it's a wide
receiver screen it's an all out blitz
the db covering the wide receiver is not
even in the screen when you're watching
it i mean he catches a ball got four
lead blockers and it's down to the one
yard line it's a you know a 35-yard gain
on on third and 15. there's just too
many big plays throughout let alone some
mix-ups and coverage and things like
that too to where
i don't know what they do but i think
they need to back off the we're gonna
blitz and get in your face and play that
style of football so much because it's
just making it too easy on some of these
offenses right now
question from at gong show west we may
need to pull up the full list of power
rankings to answer this properly but
which of the top seven teams and they
are the steelers chiefs saints ravens
titans bills seahawks which is fugazi
and most likely to drop out of the top
seven by the end of the season wow
wow that is a tough one there
i don't i don't have one in the top
seven that i look at and just go
absolute fugazi
i don't i don't know if there's one
there i mean really i think the one i
probably am questioning more than
anything right now is the tennessee
titans
i would say that to a degree because
their defense has been so poor
they can't get a pass rush
people throw the ball all over them
people run the ball over them i mean
it's mike grebel there's a 25th ranked
defense in the sport
and you know the offense has
shown a little
issues too here as of late to where it's
not been as overpowering that way so i
guess if i'm gonna pick one
that's gonna be it but the next three
weeks are gonna really tell us about the
tennessee titans because it's colts
ravens colts and we'll i'll really be
we'll really be able to answer that
question uh what do you what do you
think mike are you gonna go with
tennessee you got another team you think
fugazi-ish i i need to see tennessee of
those seven i need to see them
re-establish themselves and then if we
extend it beyond seven that you know the
packers even though they had a great
week nine because they won convincingly
they saw the saints beat the bucks which
helps the packers in the race for the 1c
they have the seahawks lose which helps
them i they've got that weird
thing that just can pop up out of
nowhere
and bring them down and i don't like
that no i shot against the bucks we saw
it against the vikings we saw it last
year every time they played in
california that there's just something
about the packers that it's impossible
for me to completely trust because you
never know when they're going to step in
a trap and the traps seem to be
plentiful when it comes to the green bay
packers and i feel like that could screw
things up for them yeah um another how
about this question from big daddy
bustard
because we have the dolphins at nine
and the bucks at ten do you really think
miami is florida's best chance at making
a super bowl well we can forget about
the jaguars obviously it comes down to
the dolphins and the bucks
and right now
the way things are moving for the miami
dolphins the way they're playing the way
they're winning
i feel better about them than i feel
about that team that got plastered on
sunday night
yeah i i i mean it is easy to feel good
about the dolphins right now where
they're where they're going everything
like that
i don't know i mean that was one that i
was going to talk about like your your 8
9 10 area there
where
i thought was interesting i probably
would have put the bucks in front of the
dolphins you know yeah the bucks played
a crap game last night i started i still
got to see more
from tua and that offense and not to i'm
not it was great start last week but
that cardinals defense is not exactly
the steel curtain and the way in which
they use tua as i think i've explained
to you that formula will be easily
figured out here very quickly it's going
to have to expand the offense a little
bit so that's where i want to see where
it goes i'm very excited about about
miami dolphins but man in a one game if
it was like one game we got to get in
the playoffs who are you going to pick
i'm going to pick the buccaneers on that
matchup right now
i think there's something about the
dolphins that is psychological they have
been so mediocre for so long i think
teams are going to have a hard time
taking them seriously
even as they win and win and win and win
i i think it just takes time and and
let's let's let's be candid about it the
uniforms are awful can we please go back
to the to the old ones with the the
dolphin on the helmet that's jumping and
it looks like a real dolphin not some
stylized graphic that you paid way too
much to have someone make for you they
just there's nothing intimidating about
the dolphins uniform can we get some
intimidation there that's the one thing
about that arizona miami game
it was fun to watch
but both uniforms are horrible like a
mildly perturbed bird is on the side of
the cardinals helmet and this
weird-looking dolphin graphic on the
mind i i just it's i just think it's
hard to take the dolphin seriously
because of the years of mediocrity and
there's nothing intimidating about
that that collection of jerseys and
pants and helmets well it's never been
well it's never been but i i don't know
i mean they dominated the 70s and had a
lot of good times and i don't know
you're right it's it's it's florida
colors they're just they don't look
tough
you know and
you know buccaneers look tough i guess i
ended up getting i guess almost i almost
dropped them even farther i was so mad
about how they made us look bad for
picking them they're lucky they're only
number 10. they should count their
blessings i know it's very important to
them where they are in my power rankings
you're lucky you're not 15 17 or 20
tampa bay buccaneers after that egg you
late on sunday night oh i know you
wanted to get personal and really drive
oh
i was mad
how dare you make us look stupid tampa
bay buccaneers how dare um
all right that's uh that's probably all
we need to talk about i'm looking
through these questions if there's
another good one uh how how about this
yeah i like this from at wolf pack
at wolf
49 ack which i don't know uh
where is the line
for the teams that should be
tanking
where is it right now
where you would and maybe we need to put
the graphic up where how bad do you have
to be
to to just throw in the towel after nine
weeks and say
we only win by losing
i i mean
i think anybody with two wins should be
just about in that conversation
i mean i i would think be thinking about
that certainly i mean hey we know you
know jacksonville the jets are in that
conversation but
when you start to get to the chargers in
houston the two and six
you know
and then the in the football team at two
and six so long yeah but they can still
win the division i i think the dividing
line for me right now leave the graphic
up i think it's between 26 and 27
because the giants in washington are
still alive to win their division i
think 27 through 32 they should be
activating tank mode now i wouldn't even
the more you lose the better off you are
i would just say i wouldn't even care if
i'm the giants or washington i wouldn't
i don't know if that's necessarily the
best thing for the team yeah i know we
want to win you know start a winning
culture and all those things too but
man
i mean i don't know how either one of
those teams even though are in the
conversation still in the nfc east
that they they're smart enough to know
that they have no chance and at some
point you just got to go okay you know
yeah we want to win be better get
something grow something here but you
know at the same time i i would think
some of those teams yeah you start to
think about positioning a little bit as
far as the draft is concerned
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports